hallo leute heute ist tag der plätzchen
ist ein kurioser feiertag der glaube ich
aus amerika kommt und ich wollte ja im
dezember alle feiertage feiern
also machen wir heute auf die suche nach
richtig leckeren plätzchen aber vorher
muss ich noch zum ausdruck denn ich bin
jetzt fashion blogger und das ist ein
lama oder alpaka ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher
schreibt man die kommentare studiosus
dort arbeiten die leute und ich stehe
und rede mit einer kamera as usual das
ist die annahme der dreh ich gleich
hallo ich zeige euch immer das set
schönes etwas macht ihr so ich muss noch
plätzchen finden ich habe so loos auf
plätzchen ich frage mal durch die
anderen absolut plätzchen haben
neben richtig witziges video und zwar
bekomme ich ein hässliches teil also ein
teil was man jetzt nicht so gleich
kaufen würde
und jana habe ich auch ein hässliches
teil ausgesucht was wirklich um mein
gott leute wenn ihr das seht die jacke
das ist eine jacke nicht ausgesucht habe
so und die zeigen wir uns gleich die
sachen und dann müssen wir halt ein
outfit drumrum basteln und ich bin schon
gespannt ob ich das hinkriege weil wer
mich kennt ich bin jetzt nicht gerade
die größte fashion tante
wir sind über den klamotten also wer
weiß ob es was wird das habe ich jetzt
schon mal an mein outfit of the day und
kaffee trinke ich die ganze zeit weißt
du denn welcher tag heute ist
und was ist der 4 dezember für tag noch
nicht heute ist tag der plätzchen
wirklich ja was ist denn dein
lieblingsplätzchen so erste teil ist
abgedreht ich habe jetzt mein outfit
zusammengestellt aber bevor wir jetzt
wirklich uns umziehen gibt es noch
lecker aber keine plätzchen obwohl tag
der plätzchen ist machen die plätzchen
suchen jetzt herausgestellt
der dreh ist jetzt vorbei und ich habe
natürlich die taktik ich durfte das
outfit behalten was ich da an hatte und
ja
es sind sehr schöne sache ich bin zwar
happy und ich liebe es sachen geschenkt
zu kriegen also dankeschön für die
klamotten aber das war ja gar nicht die
mission des tages meine mission des
tages ist es fix ausstecher zu finden
und plätzchen zu essen denn dieser tag
sketchen und wie kann man es dann besser
machen als mit coolen ausstechformen
aber ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau wo
ich auch stehe fände und vor allem kohle
und ich finde mich es noch plätzchen
backen aber ist das schon so spät
es ist schon dunkel also auf jeden fall
ziemlich seltsam mit einer kamera durch
die stadt zu laufen
ich bin halt kein blogger und wenn
derzeit überhaupt nicht gewohnt aber ich
glaube ich mache das eigentlich ganz gut
fragt man die leute die ich so
hundehaufen erwischt
okay leute warum sollte man eine hand
ausstechen
ich bin jetzt sind ausgerastet habe wir
mit 20 euro für keks ausstecher und eine
keksdose ich habe noch eine keksdose
kunden zeige ich euch gleich ich bin
sehr stolz darauf jetzt überlege ich wie
könnte ich noch den tag der plätzchen
feiern vielleicht auch weihnachtsmarkt
gehen und plätzchen kaufen kann man auf
dem weihnachtsmarkt plätzchen kaufen ich
habe das noch nie gemacht
das wird mir jetzt heraus
so ich bin jetzt auf dem alexanderplatz
nach dem mädchen
was ich bin auf der suche nach plätzchen
heute ist welt platzieren tagen also ich
dachte ich und denke mir so den kenne
ich doch hallo holly gegen einen kurs im
dezember nicht hin sagt ein video auf
mal wirklich olli hat mir den tipp
gegeben
wie kannst du noch mal sagen die heißen
schneebälle klar ist jedenfalls dass es
wie er sein komplettes blech keksen imst
von das zu einer gigantischen kugel
zusammen fonds und dann darfst du
beweisen
da gibt es rund 20 verschiedene
gespräche das handy das ist ganz viel
ausgesprochene plätzchen zu einer kugel
zusammen
das brauche ich okay das war gerade nur
mega witzig einfach mal die spaces
getroffen
ich habe es doch liegt so gefunden bei
lebe man jetzt geht's nach hause dann
gibt es plätzchen partie
hallo und wie kam in meiner kirche ich
habe heute gar keine zeit platz sind
selber zu backen aber das sollte uns
nicht daran hindern den tag der
plättchen gebührend zu feiern
mit plätzchen und kaffee
lasst uns plätzchen essen doch schon ein
bisschen weihnachtlich eingerichtet ein
ganz bisschen ich möchte mich zu meinem
lama alpaka tier setzen ich weiß es
nicht könnte es besser sein dass ich
besser sein
willkommen in meiner show
es findet ein kleiner plätzchen hall es
darf nicht die süßeste keksdose die
jemals gesehen habt die sind riesig wow
das ist so groß wie meiner hand wir
vergleichen jetzt ein teures plätzchen
für ein plätzchen für zwei euro was
super schön kraft dekoriert ist einige
bett mischung von rewe für 39 950 und es
war so krass wie dieses basics und only
auf den weihnachtsmann getroffen habt
und olli hat mir den besten tipp gegeben
das ist einfach ein plätzchen kugel
wünsche ich ein phone plätzchen tag
warum haben arbeitstag habe ich mir auch
verdient wie schmeckt ein fertig
vanillekipferl ich habe hier immer nur
selbst gebacken gegessen und noch nie so
fertig gekauft selbst gebacken schon
besser dieser keks ist bunt der schön
das mag man noch gar nicht essen es tut
mir leid weil wir in bayern ab okay
leute jetzt gehts aber ans eingemachte
jetzt ist aber schluss mit lustig wir
essen einen keks weil der rotenburger
schneeball oder so kennt ihr in einer
von euch ist das lecker und damit haben
wir den plätzchen tag erfolgreich
gefeiert würde ich sagen und wir sehen
uns eigentlich schon morgen wieder
ich hoffe ich habe es gefallen
vielleicht schaffe ich es morgen
bisschen mehr zu film morgen habe ich
keinen anderen dreh deswegen kann ich
das vielleicht machen das hier heute auf
jeden fall verpasst habt wir machen noch
eine sache zusammen die ganz wichtig ist
liebes tagebuch heute hab ich das vierte
adventskalender natürlich in abgemacht
und das war schokolade gewinn vermitteln
schock beim adventskalender gibt es
jeden tag einen spruch zu der süßigkeit
warst du liebst lass frei kommt es
zurück gehört es dir für immer konfuzius
dankeschön und damit sage ich bis morgen